[Music]  Tom Brady's ex Bridget Moynahan cheers  on his rival team on Super Bowl Sunday  in a close game against the Philadelphia  Eagles Brady's team the New England  Patriots took a loss at Super Bowl 52 in  Minneapolis at for the Philadelphia  Eagles the long drive is over but one  reaction in the fourth quarter got fans  attention Grady's ex and mother of his  eldest son John rooting for the Eagles  she tweeted Nick Foles  is having an amazing game of course Nick  is the quarterback for the Eagles who  went on to become MVP of the NFL game  some replied to Moynihan's tweets saying  she threw shaded Brady but the actress  did eventually congratulate the Patriots  on an amazing game the Patriots  quarterback did have a loyal fan and his  wife Gisele Bundchen from start to  finish she shared a pig consoling her  husband after a tough loss writing in  the caption congratulations Patriots for  giving your best and to my love we are  incredibly proud of you  [Music]